So enough.
Yeah,
I'm pretty good with pain.
Doesn't really bug me.
What about a edibles?
Haven't really done it.
You don't fuck with animals really?
I haven't had anything for 10 years.
Nothing,
nothing.
Zero.
No alcohol,
no weed,
no nothing.
Damn.
Yeah,
10 years,
which was a big,
well after my accident as well,
I was fed,
you know,
four months in a hospital being fed morphine every day for four months and then
being on all these bipolar meds and everything else,
I honestly didn't want to put anything on my body when I got out.
I didn't even take painkillers when I got home.
Now.
What kind of bipolar meds they put you on?
Dude,
I don't even remember.
I was on like four or five,
just bipolar and they,
I mean I had like,
I had so many,
I probably had like 12 medications I got sent home with and I did it for about a
week or two and then I wouldn't see my doctor.
I had actually overheard one of my friends talking who was like a brother to me
and I had heard him talking to someone else and he was like,
Yo,
like to Travis seems a little different,
you know,
like it seems a little bit slow or something.
And,
and I had overheard him.
He didn't know I overheard him,
but I was,
these meds,
I had been telling my docs too.
I was like,
I just don't feel like me.
I feel,
I don't know,
I feel weird and I just don't feel like myself.
So I just flushed them down the toilet one day and the next week I came back to
see him and he's like,
how are you doing?
I said,
good,
I'm off all of those meds you told me I'd be on for the rest of my life.
And they're like,
oh dude,
from what you've been through,
like you,
you,
it's okay to be on something like that.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm doing fine though.
Like I don't need those,
you know?
And he said he wanted to put you on a,
because of the plane crash.
Yeah.
They're like,
don't shame yourself,
you know,
by giving yourself a hard time that you have to take these pills.
And I said,
well,
you know,
I honestly,
I don't feel like they're doing what they're supposed to for me.
And that actually happened like a negative effect on me,
so I don't,
I really don't want to take them.
You know,
they also told me I'd never run again.
I'd never do this.
I never do that again.
So I think I just got to the point where I was like,
let me see how many things I can prove otherwise that they've told me.
You know,
once I stopped taking the pills,
Jesus.
So they put you on bipolar medication because of a traumatic crash?
Yeah,
that seems odd to me.
I mean,
I'm not a doctor obviously,
but,
well,
I was kind of crazy,
you know,
I was like suicidal when I was in the hospital.
Um,
I was on so many drugs I could even,
I didn't even know my friends had passed away.
I didn't even know the two pilots had passed away.
I didn't remember anything.
I kept thinking like everyone was in the hospital,
including the two pilots,
including my two best friends and am I thought everyone was just in different
rooms till about two weeks before I left.
And then I went crazy.
Then it was like they had a,
you know,
51 50 case on their hands.
You know,
I wasn't,
I wasn't in a good place.
So yeah.
Then I did,
I did a lot of like post traumatic like therapy when I was in the hospital to
kind of like calm things down.
Um,
once I got through all my surgeries and then,
yeah,
I mean,
over time it was,
it was cool,
but it was never cool,
but I started to feel better,
you know.
Um,
but yeah,
I think it was because I was so crazy at the time.
But that's,
it's interesting that,
that I would think that bipolar medication would be something that you would
give someone who has like a condition that just is sort of pre predisposed to
it.
Yeah.
I don't know anything about bipolar,
but I would think that that's something that you just have,
you know,
it's like you have a mental condition.
I wouldn't think that it would be something that they would give you to overcome
a traumatic incident.
Yeah.
I think they were afraid I was gonna be,
I had like a mental condition after everything happened.
You know,
they think like maybe because you're an artist that you're probably a little
crazy anyway.
Possibly.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
I think,
but I was a mess too.
Like,
you know,
like I had done,
I'd smoked so much weed,
you know,
every,
every day and I'd taken so many pills and I would self medicate quite a bit that
I woke up probably out of 11 at my 30 surgeries I had in the burn center,
I woke up swinging on doctors.
So it's because I would wake up and I would just,
I'd be opened up and I would just go crazy.
Jesus Christ.
So trying to get off the table.
Yeah.
I would just try to get off the table.
I don't even think I really knew what was going on.
I just wasn't,
they couldn't give me enough medication and knock me out cause I had been self
medicating for so long and abusing meds for so long.
Wow.
So you would get up from anesthesia,
you would just wake up in the middle of anesthesia.
So yeah,
that was,
that was a problem.
Um,
how did you clean up?
I think after that,
I think the last time I swung on a doctor,
they were kinda like,
you,
you're not going to,
you can't be here no more.
And then I was like,
wow,
well I need x amount of more surgeries.
And I,
I really was just fighting demons.
You know,
I had just figured out,
like my two best friends had passed away and the pilots had passed away and I
was just like in an ugly place.
And,
um,
you know,
my,
my kids couldn't come visit me because 65% of my body was burnt,
so I couldn't be around people.
So I was just in it,
man.
And then,
um,
and then I just,
I don't know.
I turned a corner and then I was like a team player and I don't think I was on
as many meds.
Most of my surgeries were over and just learning how to walk again.
Um,
being able to take a shower by myself again,
all that stuff,
man.
I,
I think that was just,
those are the good points that helped me turn the corner.
And I don't know,
I just had more strength,
you know?
So.
Wow.
So you just just turned a corner in your mind and just sort of accepted it and,
yeah.
Same with drugs.
Like I didn't never do rehab or anything.
I think it was mainly my kids and just a second life,
a second chance at life was enough for me.
I was like,
I don't,
I never want to do any of that stuff again,
you know?
That's cool.
So once you get a certain amount of distance between you and those days,
does it seem like,
like it wasn't even real,
it wasn't you doing those things,
you look back and you're just like,
fuck yeah,
I still talk to those doctors to this day.
Like Dr Grossman.
He's,
uh,
he's,
he's so awesome.
And he,
he basically saved my life,
you know.
Um,
but I still talk to him and he lives out here in the valley and he has Grossman
burn center.
And I go over there at Christmas and,
and see burn,
you know,
burn victims that are over there in the,
in the burn center and help out any way I can.
But yeah,
he's great man.
That's really cool.
Yeah.
Um,
many of my friends that I know that I had real bad drug problems and then now
are off drugs,
they look back and they go,
what?
I don't,
what the fuck was I doing?
Like how did I do?
How was that me?
It's interesting how that happens in your life,
who you have these new chapters in your life and,
and then sometimes it could just be something that happened like two weeks ago
and you're like,
who the fuck was that guy two weeks ago?
I'm not even him anymore.
Yeah.